people of the internet it is actually
happening I can't believe this you guys
I mean I always thought there was a
chance but I did not expect it this soon
an official dedicated stand-alone
Quidditch game this is not April Fool's
I seriously had to check the Tweet like
five times to make sure this was in fact
legit but we can confirm WB has
officially announced Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions and you can sign up
right now to be part of the play test
we're going to go through all the
information right now there's a brand
new website quidditch
champions.wbgames.com and they have an
official FAQ page there so right from
the top here Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions is a fast-paced competitive
multiplayer game featuring the world's
most iconic magical sport so obviously
multiplayer there big news no
multiplayer component whatsoever in
Hogwarts Legacy no quidditch component
in Hogwarts Legacy which is something
that a lot of fans wanted clearly they
knew this but little did we know that
they knew it this whole time as you're
gonna see here in a bit this has
actually been in development for a while
so next question who is publishing
Warner Brothers games is publishing
Harry Potter Quidditch Champions under
the portkey games label this is exactly
the same as Hogwarts Legacy right there
who is developing Harry Potter quiddish
Champions this is where it gets
different Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions has been in development for
several years by unbroken Studios some
games that they have been a part of
Suicide Squad killed the Justice League
they're working with Rocksteady on that
of course that one is not out yet
according to their website unbroken
Studios is an LA based team of 93
developers with proven track records of
working on some of the most memorable
franchises such as Battlefield Call of
Duty God of War and the Arkham series
but from what we know about all these
franchises they certainly weren't the
lead developer on any of these you know
those are some big names right there
Battlefield Call of Duty God of War
Arkham and they're a relatively small
team so from what I can tell right now
it seems like this is their first
dedicated project that they have solely
been in charge of now I'm gonna do more
research on that and we'll be sure to
update you guys in a future video but
biggest takeaway for me right here is
they clearly have experience working on
some top-notch multiplayer titles I mean
Battlefield Call of Duty you're talking
some of the big time Heavy Hitters right
there and I've already seen some people
asking is this connected to Hogwarts
Legacy in any way seems to be here the
answer is no they have a question here
that says is Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions a standalone experience and
the answer is yes Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions is a complete Standalone
quidditch experience developed by
unbroken Studios it engages players in
the sport of quidditch and other
broomstick Adventures alongside friends
and a competitive multiplayer setting
which can we just pause for a second
this is exactly exactly what most of us
have been asking for I know a lot of
people were upset that Hogwarts Legacy
did not have quidditch but many of us
who followed Hogwarts Legacy along the
way said no to do quidditch right you
really need to have someone develop that
from the ground up focusing solely on
quidditch and that is exactly what WB
has done here where can I play Harry
Potter Quidditch Champions this one is
really important guys you need to go
right now if you're interested in this
game go to the official website sign up
because it is in limited play testing
right now I saw signed up as soon as
this announcement dropped I have not
received anything yet but as soon as I
do whether it's good or bad whether I
get in or not I will be sure to let you
guys know when does Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions release a release
date for Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions has not been set now the fact
that it's in limited play testing
already I think is a very good sign that
means they clearly have a playable
version of the game ready to go I've not
seen any footage yet whatsoever though
so I don't know if that's rolling out
today this week this month this year if
Harry Potter magic awakened has taught
us anything it's that you just never
know with these things magic awakened
has been apparently very close to
releasing multiple times in the US and
the UK and other territories and then
they've hit some sort of stumbling block
that's prevented that from happening but
the way this right here reads I think
we're going to be getting our hands on
this game very very soon at least in
this limited play test version what
platforms will Harry Potter Quidditch
Champions be available on and then they
say that it's going to be available for
PC and consoles which have not yet been
confirmed now here's the interesting
thing about that even though they say
the consoles have not been confirmed
when you go to sign up for the play test
it actually asks you which platform do
you play games on in Xbox One Xbox
series X and S PS4 PS5 switch PC laptop
PC desktop all of those are available
however if I were you I would not take
that as an assumption that it will for
sure be available on all of those can
players customize their character in
Harry Potter Quidditch Champions yes
players can create and customize their
own quidditch Champions does Harry
Potter Quidditch Champions require an
internet connection yes Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions is a competitive
multiplayer experience that requires an
internet connection to play so that's a
big one right there guys and it connects
directly to this next question can I
play Harry Potter Quidditch Champions
with my friends yes you can play Harry
Potter Quidditch Champion Solo or team
up with friends or others online now the
solo part has me a little bit confused
because the question right before it
says you have to have an online
connection to play so what I think they
mean by solo here is that yes you can
solo queue but the game itself is still
online you're still going to be in there
with other people people as you're
playing now I could be wrong about that
but I don't think we're gonna have like
any CPU games where it's like you versus
the computer we'll keep an eye on this
and see if they update that question and
then all of those other questions I'll
just leave those for you to read on your
own if you follow the development of
Hogwarts Legacy then all of those are
going to be familiar to you they don't
relate to this game specifically but
more about portkey games as a whole so
my initial Impressions right now guys to
be honest with you is one of shock not
that this is actually happening because
I always thought especially after the
success of Hogwarts Legacy they will
make a Quidditch game one day but I did
not realize it was actually already in
development for several years as the FAQ
says there okay now as the excitement
starts to wane though now we actually
start have to ask the real questions
right how does the game actually play
how much is it going to cost is it
better that quidditch World Cup it seems
like we're going to be able to play all
the positions WB tweeted out in their
announcement and they said calling all
beaters Chasers Keepers and Seekers so
the fact that they're calling out all
the positions there and the fact that
they're making a dedicated Quidditch
game I mean I think it's pretty clear
that it is going to include all the
positions but will they change up the
rules because as you guys know if you've
read the books or seen the movies it is
certainly skewed in favor of the Seeker
being very important kind of determining
everything else that happens with the
game and it's a little bit one-sided so
I think you could have a weird scenario
if this is an online game where a team
is just dominating and then the seeker
comes in and catches the snitch actually
kind of similar to what happened in the
Quidditch roll cup and Goblet of Fire I
don't know that that would play well
with a video game audience especially
for an online multiplayer game where
people are going to be highly
competitive in this I guarantee you but
when I think about all the different
mini game options and all the different
tournament options and all of the extra
things that they can do with this game
it is so incredibly exciting especially
because I know you guys the community
have really wanted something like this
quidditch was by far one of the most
requested things for Hogwarts Legacy as
was multiplayer as much as people loved
Hogwarts Legacy I still think there was
a huge portion of the audience who
really wanted to be able to play with
others play with your friends now I'm
still holding out hope for an MMO at
some point as well but right now I
cannot wait to try this out hopefully
I'll get in we'll see fingers crossed
see if we can get into this and as soon
as we get that Hands-On time then we'll
certainly have that up here on the
channel and you guys already know we're
going to keep you up to date with
everything happening with Harry Potter
Quidditch Champions if you want more
content like that be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss any of it as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon